today on our show the directors of the
young Han Solo movie get frozen and
Carbonite taken away by Boba Fett - a
galaxy where they're no longer directing
the Han Solo moods long way of saying
that the on solo directors got fired
holy [ __ ] we're gonna dive deep into the
latest dire development the Star Wars
saga today on fat man on Batman holy
[ __ ]
that men on that man well with that man
a Batman I'm Kevin Smith
holy [ __ ] I'm working on we still can't
believe it I can't believe it can you
believe no dude this never happened this
is unprecedented ladies and gentlemen I
asked mark when he got here I was like
you remember last time some director got
replaced on a major motion picture deep
into productions one thing if you you
know creative differences in Orion that
happen with that great and ant-man and
stuff like that sometimes you just don't
blend well you all think it's good
working together you'll sit in a room
for why like we can do this right no we
can't do this it's time to go our
separate ways but there's literally
never hundreds of millions of dollars
already put into motion to make that
happen they're happily shooting yeah
when they announced the story today I
was like well thank God they had start
shooting because I'm a STONER and I
forgot and also I've even but I live a
life anymore I'll know things but I
forgot that they started shooting this
motion picture ready showed us that
[ __ ] red cup you know in the called
production red cup on the on the Slater
yes oh [ __ ]
everyone seem like they have a good time
as a picture everyone in the cockpit
everyone smiling [ __ ] laughing hokum
remember Star Wars not working here's on
solo by the way years long yes everybody
the [ __ ] cockpit sleaze behind us but
we're going to make a billion dollars
and then we wake up today and if I could
pull the rug out from under these dudes
weather names Lord and the Lord and
Christopher Miller dudes are geniuses I
don't know them at all never met him and
[ __ ] and I know those 21 Jump Street
movies are funny but that lego movie
these dudes get a pass for life that
lego movie is one of the greatest magic
ever made by human beings but amazing
the 21 like these are the guys who
somehow bomb into a product a product
that you didn't think you wanted now and
deliver you something that you can't
live without I would agree with that all
three of the movies that have guests
combined made over a billion dollars
yeah easy
those 21 Jump Street movies and the lego
movie it when I first serve I didn't
watch the 21 Jump Street movies and
theaters I Solomon home another holy
[ __ ] this shit's genius and then lego
movie I first heard about like yeah your
[ __ ] mind
why do out of your mind why do I want
this and then I wanted more of
and I know their names on the Batman
Lego move down on my side to do with
that but these dudes could do no wrong
in my book and they also directed an
executive produce with Will Forte last
man on earth on Fox
which if you've never seen Brett a very
sensational highlight they directed the
pilot it is one of the best comedy
pilots I've ever seen because comedy
takes a long while to get out of the
gate it's iteration it's figuring it out
it's it's it's doing it over and over to
find your street to define your stride
that pilot is great it's the first thing
you've ever seen from it these guys are
really good at the things that they do
these dudes the legit when I asked him
as I can you think any directors he
couldn't take the one I thought to
Island dr. Moreau dredgen remember he
got fired into the shooting and he hung
around money I am watching him shooting
in the makeup is like a lion person
could kind of oh yeah I kind of like I
don't if I remember correctly but anyway
he got they parted ways and then when
they were making duplex over at Miramax
way back in the day Greg Mottola who
went on to direct super bad amongst
those things he was the director of
duplex and I think Ben Stiller was like
the king and then they brought in Danny
DeVito finish the movie so this is just
a long way so and I'm sure there's been
more but like yeah it happening in the
middle of a [ __ ] production on one of
the highest profile films the Disney
will make this year yeah I mean it
happens in sunny Star Wars movie after
the next Star Wars movie having them pre
all the time happens in post
occasionally as we just saw with Zack
Snyder and Joss Whedon that when you
finish production when you're done being
the army captain on set and you're not
finding it and post the way you need to
find in a post sometimes they will bring
in another director and finish it off it
did it on road one yeah sometimes it's
because of disaster and Zacks part but
sometimes it's we just didn't happen
Gareth Edwards is director of lobe one
and very famously now they brought in
Tony Gilroy to direct some sequences
this this isn't even that no because Gil
where I got to retain his title as
director and nobody said you're fired
this is literally those dudes got
shit-canned yes fired and the nearest we
could figure based on The Hollywood
Reporter article
oh is that and let's before we you know
dive deeper we we sucked on the dick of
those two dudes deservingly let's talk
on Kathy Kennedy's dick which sounds
weirder than I meant it
well the most successful producer in the
business bar none I think she's the
highest grossing producer like even over
Jerry Bruckheimer gay like that
she is Star Wars legacy goes back how
far with Lucas Films I mean she goes
back to she was a assistant on Raiders
and she was also gonna be on Empire as
well um I think she might have been yeah
once she joined Amblin and when she gets
in that thing she meets frank marshall
on the set of Raiders they wind up
getting married the one who get married
but that's she's absolutely in that
swirl for a long time and look back in
her long track record of films like
she's no dummy this wasn't it's like
[ __ ] flighty decision she's [ __ ] a
brilliant woman who knows how to make a
major motion picture
I've got motion pictures I make but like
this [ __ ] cost 200 million and Scott
Han Solo in it so she knows what she's
doing the other player in this Passion
Play would be
Lawrence Kasdan and I get close to your
ni family should I read Lawrence Kasdan
the great Larry Kasdan the man without
whom there is no Empire State well maybe
there is but it is good as the Empire
Strikes Back is he wrote that screenplay
and he also wrote Raiders right he was
uh George lands George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg's go-to guy for writing back
and then he went on become a famous
director in his own right did body heat
did The Big Chill it is over ottoman
silverado unloved it awesome who loved
it
well the greatest westerns ever made
yeah I think we had at some point talked
about the there's a thing that exists
online called the Raiders story
conference yeah which is just like it's
it's it's a typewritten transcript of
the two or three times the George Lucas
team Spielberg and Louis guys are in a
room breaking the story for Raiders and
just watching it be shaped from what am
i great if we do like a serial about a
guy's maybe a spy and maybe a treasure
hunter I don't know who goes after
something what you go after like
literally it's les invent rated Lost Ark
and you can read them do it Wow Larry
Kasdan is the other dude in that room
Larry Kasdan is Hollywood royalty
Lucasfilm a legacy so he is also in
impune and tuneable yeah sure we could
do that impenetrable will do
impenetrable now your bullet that guy
you've taken down with kryptonite bullet
just like super really uh none of them
they're all of their reputations
you cannot impugn [ __ ] isn't imputable I
don't unit we made a word imputable
these people unimpeachable unimpeachable
all three of these parties involved in
the story as we understand it from our
reporter mind use talking to dudes
talking about it don't know anymore new
we can read it online we don't even have
like [ __ ] would you hear from friends
I don't have any friends that on all
three parties Kathy Kennedy Larry Kasdan
and send your Lego boys
but Larry son Jake Jake Kasdan co-wrote
it with him no not Jake Jake is the
director [ __ ] John I think isn't sure
yeah look it up no muss John is sure for
Jake could well Jake goes by Jake Kasdan
right this guy was not Jake Kasdan if I
remember correctly he pause what his
phone's off
ah check him out I think it's another
it's not Jake I must Jake it suddenly
going by a new name mm-hmm but in any
event his kid is I mean I'm not taking
his kid out of equation saying [ __ ] him
no you're right I'm sorry Johnny
jaelyn well done I read much I read the
oliver point
you only worked there extra send him I
thought okay so he's like without doing
all due respect to the kid these new
being this was not solution line no it
comes down to Larry Kasdan Kathy Kennedy
and the Lego boys we remember all three
of them like I can see across the
board's
like none of these people are feckless
all of them have bona fides on the
big-budget level this ain't like a
couple Sundance kids made a cute movie
and now they got a big budget flick
these cats did their time as well and
turn [ __ ] straw into gold
so who's the bad guy in the situation
seems like they're maybe
it just comes down to [ __ ] that old
chestnut creative differences right I
mean here's the statements the two
statements are got released today one
from Kathy Kennedy which says Phil Lloyd
and Christopher Miller are talented
filmmakers so two assembled an
incredible cast and crew but it's become
clear to what they're fired yeah but
[ __ ] them in their asses but it's been
clear that we had different creative
visions on the film we've decided to
part ways new director will be announced
soon
let's Kathy Kennedy Lord Miller said
unfortunately our vision and process
weren't aligned with our partners in
this project we normally aren't fans of
the phrase creative differences but for
once this cliche is true we're really
proud of the amazing and world-class
work of our cast and crew
I also added everything is awesome
everything is cool when you're part of a
team which we are now not yes
thanks a lot storm these are things that
like you usually see the kind of
releases that come out even Milind
Laurie said it sounds like a cliche
creative differences nobody ever really
knows what goes on beyond creative
differences but this time [ __ ]
get fired
yeah they got fired on Mondays no it's
not at least need to tech to I
understand they didn't even know it was
Gavin it was like they were blindsided
on you're kidding
they had production had been at a hiatus
or a halt they seem to be doing that now
with the Star Wars movies get a little
deep in and take a breather to figure
they did it on force awakens they had to
and had support buses like they did it
on road one and that's led them to the
reshooting or the Tony Gilroy of it all
and now it looks like they're planning
to do it for this movie as well so the
way I understand it again just from the
articles I've read these cats went into
the break on well they said in the
article that it was suicide it was all a
reporter article to assess the where
they were in the movie right and to like
clear the air which the second part of
the statement clear there is the more
telling them the first that means
there's air to clear right that means
that there was some sort of conflict
between Miller and Lord and the Kasden
boys or Miller and Lord and Cathy
Kennedy but as our reporter he tells us
it was it was and again he keep throwing
to Kasdan boys and it's Lawrence castor
this is mine but if those cans also
advocating for his son so you get a bit
of Adam so he wrote it too
yes but it's not I honestly feel like
he's got a reputation as being like the
do the script and these guys the Lego
boys they're the cats are like say
something funny yeah they came out of TV
and hey you know [ __ ] be a funny
people be cast funny people and there's
no wrong way like some people like while
like my Star Wars were serious what Star
Wars has always had a sense of humor to
it and maybe these guys are just going
to jack it up a little bit there nothing
wrong with that and stuff but their
vision for the movie apparently very
different from yeah the House version of
the movie which is written by Lawrence
Kasdan and his kid and Kathy is George
Lucas for all intents purposes and you
can't I'm not saying they're wrong but
it's like you can't argue with like
there's no wrong or right choice there's
the choice you make when you're
confronted with these two options and
she chose I'm gonna go with legacy I'm
gonna go with the dudes who pretty much
gave us the Han Solo that everybody
loves to back their boys back Laura
Clarence Clarence Cavs and later Kevin
who she's known for 40 years yeah that
makes absolute sense yes who also
delivered big beyond whatever the [ __ ]
else were talking about he co-wrote
Force awakens he well he helped save
Force awakens at one point I remember
critically right like yeah I mean I
think I mean the two of them like he's
got screenplay credit there's all of
these like the the documentation of the
shoot where it's him and JJ sitting next
to each other on the set like going over
the script like he was in the first
reading when you saw that cast victory
but he's sitting around there's long as
Katherine the corner like you wonder
where's Michael aren't sure he'll be
here later on crying it is Toy Story 3
money my my tears so [ __ ] fat 40
money to infinity and beyond making it
rain so the first time Star Wars has
fired somebody or you know parted ways
michael arndt Weezer's we just talked
about
josh trank yeah the director of
fantastic for now he's directing a movie
with Tom Hardy right now so he's working
again he's out of movie Jail good for
josh trank but josh trank would let go
from the Beaux black movie yeah I don't
think I broke that I think that's anyone
do that
it's a boba fett mone but and now they
got nobody on the books that movie I
don't think I don't think I picked up
another dress
- now so it's not you know unheard of
but it's it's very unheard of in the
movie business or at least so rare that
it makes the front page of everything
yeah that midway through production you
[ __ ] change horses midstream you cut
your directors loose like those dudes
were fired color it any way you want
creative differences whatnot but they
were like I'm sorry this is as far as
you go and they didn't know it was going
to happen
they knew a minute before we did
apparently yeah like suddenly their key
cards don't work on the door and this is
security dude outside this may be one of
the only documented cases in Hollywood
history with a writer can't be [ __ ]
with writers always like tossed aside
bent over and [ __ ] like this but man he
was the he was on hop [ __ ] cannot [ __ ]
with a writer who was going on and I
don't think they [ __ ] with him I just
think these cats were like oh my god
we've made over a billion dollars for
other studios [ __ ] doing this and you
hired us like you knew what we would do
that means I think that's that's the
weird thing it's like you know one point
I was talking to Jen Jen my wife was
just like it went when Mark showed up
she's like finally you can go talk about
this with some buddies because I was
just downstairs going like what does
this mean and going through every
scenario and [ __ ] like that
but she like you know she was we were
talking about it and you know she said
like is it really a big deal and I was
like is it like she goes it they should
have shot and you know people like why
do we give a [ __ ] what your wife says
well you'll see in a second she said
they should have shot like of course
they got fired they should have shot the
script that the studio gave her more
blah blah blah and I said yeah but
that's like hiring John Woo to make your
movie and then you're like why are these
birds and bullets is it like why would
you hire those guys who you look at
their whole track record it's not like
oh we directed clean and sober with
Michael Keaton in the midst of all these
funny movies they make funny movies and
warm like incredibly family-friendly and
also like inspiring movies that Lego
movies brilliant
but yeah they don't do [ __ ] serious
and and I'm graduating Han Solo is going
to be seriously I'm sure there'll be
some levity to it but you know like we
were before the show started I was like
I bet you those dudes got fired because
they were like for this scene we want to
score it with the Miko theme from Star
Wars and Catholic and he was like [ __ ]
this you're barred like it done it's a
shame this is a real shame because I
would have liked to see in the version
movie they [ __ ] cast it I mean don't
be let's be honest Kathy Ken Kathy
Castle is a group casting effort but a
lot of those cats probably jumped into
that movie cuz like oh I like Chris and
Tim I won't work with their dad there's
a there's a very legitimate wet world in
which people were way more excited for
young han solo movies because those guys
were doing it yeah in the same way that
I would agree look I'll see all these
movies I'm in the bag but because those
dudes were involved I was like cinemas
oh [ __ ] this is gonna be a thing like
this is gonna have some juice it was it
was very much the Edgar Wright is making
hand man yeah like that's interesting I
didn't give a [ __ ] about Ellen before
that dude on air man okay um I'm curious
to say the least and as you can see like
with ant-man it all worked out look
Edgar got to go make baby driver instead
which everyone looks forward to and you
know [ __ ] Peyton Reed it's a dream
shoot yeah man the wasp and ant-man is a
wonderful movie so this doesn't mean
disaster some people online look whose
movies book that's what they said about
rogue one and rogue one had one of the
greatest [ __ ] one-minutes of cinema
storytelling of all time let alone in a
Star Wars movie and that came out of the
reshoots yeah wasn't even part of the
original plan so I got enough money
[ __ ] throw enough money at this
problem it's [ __ ] fixed and and it
who knows what it's not like problem
would be like all [ __ ] it's broken
they were just apparently making two
different movies yeah that what it
sounds like and they are decided to make
the one movie yeah here's my question
those boys quit or I had to jump off a
flash to go do this did they go back to
flash or as Warner Brothers like go [ __ ]
yourself I can't imagine like go [ __ ]
yourselves because I like oh but they
make a lot of billion dollars so do you
think it's prodigal son time I feel like
we welcome you back kill the slaughter
the fat
lamb come we must have a feast I mean
I'm in in the post Wonder Woman world
where you want fun and bright and energy
those guys deliver that thing except in
a young Han Solo movie apparently they
don't what that I guess cuz it's dark
and cold in space in space no again you
cry when we take off bit later it's not
says movies not gonna be charming and
adorable and funny and so I'm sure it'll
happen but apparently they were mega to
different movies now
those dudes go bye-bye which is a
[ __ ] shame cuz they're brilliant but
if I'm Warner Brothers right now I'm
hiring them I'm pop any other studio on
the planet I'm hiring those dudes don't
worry about those cats they will and
I'll be fine utterly fine but yeah now
if I'm now if I'm if I'm Warner Brothers
I'm like all this a [ __ ] hurt them
let's get them here and do this just
like you heard us when they left us to
go before Wow
that's [ __ ] massive do you think this
is one thing went through my mind what
if Donald Glover was like oh I'll do
this because I like those guys and then
those guys go away just Donald Glover
stick around
I mean have to sign a copy and sign a
contract on a contract would maybe those
there's always a way out of a contract
you know I and there's also a version
which this dude as a showrunner this
dude as a writer and a producer and
director like if they're really one guy
who can help Shepherd this thing along
the way like he's sitting right there
what a great idea I mean it opening was
engineered from inside listen this Han
Solo same spider-man but I will get this
whole movie like what if it's about no
no Lando console is a guest star in the
Lando movie I know something about him
and the spider-man movie and I will tell
you after the show I can't share here
Colombian bucking I'll lose my connects
but there's something pretty awesome
yeah I will share with you that being
said I support that idea that being said
as well Larry Kasdan is right there okay
so he's director he knows the script he
was you didn't like this direction the
script was going in this is the guy who
[ __ ] created the modern day on saw
Han Solo and Empire Strikes Back and
stuff not just the one in Star Wars
so I said tap them I mean the other name
that's the floating line is Ron Howard
which I mean that made mine ours great
to rarities a great director he's got a
Lucasfilm connected willow for that last
room they'd he can absolutely just swing
into a man mata can find the humor that
they want it to be and execute on a high
level with a high budget which is a
thing that for his greatest Larry Kasdan
is as a writer and as a director of
actors he's never made a movie like this
before
and you know he'd be like oh please
[ __ ] please let that phone ring just
call come on man that race drive-in
movie didn't work out those last movie
did it i straddle movie now he did in
the heart of the sea oh he [ __ ] ass
or fading away land nobody went a man I
made sucks oh I got I'd be off for an
hour version the movie sure look I don't
give a [ __ ] get somebody in the director
chair finish this movie come in the bag
as previously stated but I think it's a
damn shame we're not going to see what
those dudes might have done but he'll
have no fury like a comic scorn so I
think it's going to result in a bunch of
great jokes and whatever they did I'm
sure it will and I'm sure there's also
as I'm imagining there always is some
circuit in Hollywood where [ __ ]
get to see the stuff that nobody else
gets to see like me here's a dead pile
of society we all watch the [ __ ] that
didn't get picked up somewhere somewhere
there's a tape of the movie that I mean
I bet you they've got some of that
footage like on laptops and whatever
wonder if like they fire them and
they're like we'll expect all that back
please after right I mean I'm sure they
would hope that their hard drives to be
wiped but crazy situation I know they
know everyone's put out nice statements
and ship if this is you know in the
first world
this is [ __ ] topsy-turvy upside down
yeah and like nobody everybody wants a
drama on the screen not behind the
screen and this is the thing that nobody
wants which is everybody just calling
[ __ ] into question for reasons that we
don't know if it manifest on the final
product but to be fair that the same
[ __ ] on rogue one yep in road one was a
be light so the pickle sucks but hey man
we're still getting a Star Wars movie
yeah maybe we'll be awesome yeah who the
[ __ ] knows probably be awesome yeah
there it is that's for - we didn't sent
along for you guys not to do with the
situation you know just interested
curious outside parties we're like
[ __ ] two old dudes it's the Muppet
Theater
we're here to use more star wars
pictures with those young guys why don't
you let Ron Howard do it little of Iowa
let him out of his cocoon oh here's a
call Danny Glover he's not too old for
this [ __ ]
Oh some of that learn world where the
comic book world man that is fat man I'm
Batman for today I'm I've been Kevin
Smith I've been Markman Arden and you be
good at your job you will get a car
potentially so hot today
I fell yeah no no coming today call it
hey Phil and Tim you want to come
somewhere and talk about this I'm sure
it's all [ __ ] fine till it's not not
sure there's gonna be a story yeah easy
stories I'm selling when I first saw
that I was like these dudes you two woke
up with [ __ ] dead girl or a live boy
and then because of that at all who's
just creative differences
yes because Mara's we know you know ah
there it is man and again we don't have
[ __ ] except what we read now we're
reading things to you yeah that's it
we read the news digest it and spit ball
about it yeah we spit ball it baby bird
style into your mouth and our opinion
like yours is worth absolutely [ __ ]
lose not right believe me give me thank
you
there it is I went out on a gross note
let's make it relevant to the [ __ ]
show though that bird that was being fed
the penguin yes and I meant man there it
is for fat man on Batman I've been Kevin
Smith and I have been mark barnard to
come back next episode same bat-time
same bat-channel podcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you